hélas sandrine arcizet nous attend
regarder ça va sandrine mais ça vas y
toi alors franchement c'est comme si je
comme si je pénétrai dans la dans la
mecque
ah ouais ça mais c'est à la jeu est si
bon nombre des corps la mettez bien
c'est bien là avec plaisir est là ouais
alors à l'ong cite une hyper super g
tous les alors ici à la scie tout au
tout et là tout est là l'afrique est ce
qu'on pourrait faire comme d'exercice
peut pas faire un exercice qu'il perd
soutenait bas du corps les squats
l'escouade très rock et squatte ouvert
ses fesses en arrière sur vraiment tu
sers les fessiers avec les foudres de
puivert les frères la pointe du doigt un
seul à wallace et bien ça c'est bien ça
fait tous les matins je fais ça tous les
matins alors bien je le fais de quoi
qu'il arrive tous les matins quand je
quand voilà j'ai fait tous les matins
mais écoutez franchement sans neige est
très juteux régime et d'être là
franchement
mais d'abord je regarde tous les matins
c'est quoi c'est vers 6h50
c'est un but pendant une heure oui c'est
un gros carton sur la chaîne me suffit
cimetière on voit depuis lors je vois en
vrai que tout ça et voilà tout ça c'est
parfait c'est parfait alors là c'est
tranquille on y va tranquille voilà
voilà voilà
hu à l'arrière je n'ai vu un pied voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà
on a banni la voilà voilà voilà mais on
rigole
bah ouais alors j'ai absolument tout les
matin 7 heures voilà c'est 6h53 je gagne
tous les matins